[Music]  looks like we have one of our first  celebrity splits of 2018  et can confirm bleachers frontman Chuck  Antonov and girls star Lena Dunham have  called it quits after five years  together things seem good between the  two in November to the point where Lena  told her Twitter followers that she  mistakenly thought Jack was about to  propose woat I thought Jack was  furtively planning a proposal to me with  his sister and he just admitted I  actually caught him quote talking [ __ ]  about me now I literally can't sleep  because I'm laughing too hard and I'm  also keeping him awake five and a half  years no rock and you know what it's  real nice but Lina seemed in good  spirits Sunday night when she stepped  out for HBO's Golden Globes after-party  rocking long hair and donning all black  in solidarity with The Times up movement  [Music]  you